to round off the evening today here I'd
like to just welcome all our speakers
again so Mario poio is the leader of
Boston Global zero great pleasure to
have you here we don't you've already
you already met
Phil or a bunch of our speakers here who
have you not met yet so Charles Ferguson
is the president of the Federation for
American scientists uh an organization
which
um be which does in my opinion a lot of
very nerdy stuff which is incredibly
important we hear everybody talking
about how many nuclear weapons there are
that all the different countries have
and how many different kinds are where
do you think that information comes
from do you think it's something that's
published in the in Pravda on the front
page and officially put up at the
military no they do a lot of hard
research people like H Christians and so
on painstaking work on all this geeky
stuff and it's so valuable to have a a
debate which is actually focused on on
facts ra rather than speculation Gary
Goldstein comes down from tough
University another one of my physics
colleagues so this is the physics Mafia
corner here Frank
wilch has also dabbled a little bit of
physics in physics they dabbled a little
bit in quirks and stuff and my my my
Swedish countrymen and gave him a free
trip to Stockholm for that one spot of
time to see if he could get him addicted
the the pickled herring and um I think
it worked you've been back to Sweden
lots of times since then as well so any
progress on them on the chair yes oh
good so
um you guys can sit down and relax for a
little bit first because we're first I'm
going to torment the panel list with a
bunch of questions but then there'll be
plenty of chances for you also so since
this is the end of of a long day I would
like to start by looking a little bit
towards the future we've been handed a
lot of challenges we've been told that
there's grave there are grave problems
here we need to solve them we would like
to end the day with feeling not only
that there are things we can do but more
specific things that would be really
really useful so I'd like to go around
once first relatively quickly and have
just each person pick out the one single
thing which they think is the most
useful thing that we can do and you can
take that you can you choose to
interpret the word we either as a
majestic plural as something you one can
do it at the individual level or in a
more broad sense if you want Gary do you
want to start off
okay uh something that I'm especially
concerned about is educating young
people uh having been a physicist and a
teacher of physics for decades uh I know
that many of the issues we have heard
about today are unknown to many of our
young people
and one place that people learn about
the physics of nuclear weapons you would
think would be in physics
classes but they don't by and large and
so I will talk about when I have time uh
an effort we are making to spread the
word that nuclear weapons are a natural
subject to address in freshman physics
Advanced physics graduate physics they
affect us all we should all be worried
about them and we should have some
knowledge about what they are about and
and how to deal with
them great over to you Frank well it's
been a very inspiring experience today
to learn so much and hear so
much about what's possible uh I think
broadly speaking the most important
thing we can do is raise consci
ious I think the most important thing we
can do is raise Consciousness and this
has several components uh raise
consciousness of the horrific nature of
nuclear
war uh raise consciousness of the costs
of enabling our outsides
capacity and raise Consciousness that
there are steps we can take to uh
eleviate the situation to alleviate the
danger and I think we heard a lot about
all those things today and there's a lot
of work to do there's a lot of thinking
to be done about how best to implement
uh this process of raising Consciousness
and take and taking concrete steps but I
think the first step is to raise our own
Consciousness and then go out into the
world so uh Max mentioned a little bit
about Federation American scientists I
feel very privileged and and humbled to
uh lead the organization it's now than
70 years uh founded soon after the end
of World War II founded by many of the
atomic scientists who uh built the first
atomic bombs the Manhattan Project so my
message is we need to reverse the
Manhattan Project and to do that we can
do you know two activities I'll briefly
mention and maybe get into more depth a
little later number one speaking to I
know there's a younger scientist who was
up there earlier asked a question of Dr
Perry and some other younger people so
we're trying to involve younger people
younger scientists younger engineers and
political scientists policy experts
working with faculty members in task
forces and study groups networked
Technical and policy people working on
these tough you know seemingly
impossible problems but Joe reny Ernie
is absolutely right The Impossible
happens all the time we just need
talented younger people working with
more senior people in these types of
projects and another thing I'll just
Telegraph is Monday of this past week we
issued a letter endorsed by 35 Nobel
laurates in The Sciences a couple of
them here at MIT calling on the national
leaders at the nuclear security Summit
calling out three technical areas where
if we make further progress we could
drive the risk of nuclear terrorism
essentially to zero in those sectors and
I can get into that more depth later if
we have time but um I will turn now to
Susie wow that's awesome
congratulations yeah um yeah Applause um
I think it's we've heard so many things
and I think for me one of the greatest
things to take away today is to remember
that we have power we have agency we can
do something how you choose to do
something whether it's as a
citizen as a a voter um as somebody with
a bank account um whatever you choose to
do you must do it whether it's as a
professor you have power to influence
this issue and I think for me that's the
most important thing to take away
because we this is a this is
terrifying but we don't we are not
powerless in the face of it so that's
where I'll hand it over to you thank you
my my message is the same as I gave my
talk which is get educated you can use
for example plow here's website our
website American scientist website Max's
website get lots of current information
about what's going on what can be done
about it so get educ and then use that
education to educate others your friends
your
neighbors um your classmates for example
you go to our website take that video
which you just saw Here download it and
then call in 10 of your neighbors play
them the video and say what do you think
of that what do you think we should do
about it get a little discussion going
on it so you yourself can be part of the
education process
that's great I agree with everything
that's been said so far let me add one
thing we haven't maybe talked enough
about I'm old enough to remember that
when
you that you had to go outside and flag
down a taxi if you actually wanted to go
someplace in the
city but there was an app that changed
the way people move in this country I
think there's tremendous potential for
apps in this field and this little
divestment app that you came up building
off of this that's a little miracle as
far as I'm concerned I didn't think that
was possible what Alex wallin's done
with
nukemap I I think there's a huge
potential for the proliferation of apps
in this
field and uh just before you start uh
Talking Mary we've had a number of
people throughout the day saying it's so
important to try to engage idealistic
and talented young people how can we get
these young people engaged well you are
one of these idealistic and talented
young people so I think there's nobody
better to answer this than you yeah so I
know um I'm actually I have something to
say to all the young people in the
audience um we um are all here because
we care about this issue um and we need
to take ownership of this issue I think
I wouldn't be here if it weren't for
Joseph Gerson um and other vet an
activists who have mentored me and um
who I could go to um and I actually just
came from the nuclear security Summit um
where me and my fellow action Corp
leaders at Global zero all young people
were together and I cannot tell you how
this combination of mentorship um from
uh other generations and fellowship with
young people like us we we can build a
movement there is so much hope um that
that I feel from from this um this
cross-section and people say people tell
me a lot oh well you know I don't know
much about nuclear weapons other than
like Fallout 4 or um maybe Doctor
Strange Love but I I think that's a
misconception about young people I think
we are passionate we are hopeful um and
I really believe that we can be the
generation to to realize a world without
nuclear weapons and so I would love to
talk to all of you young people out
there afterwards and to all um other
people who don't identify as young
people I strongly encourage you I
strongly encourage you to Mentor because
that has been the most amazing
experience for me to be in the Boston
community and have all these amazing
mentors to draw
from that's wonderful thank you so much
for all seven of you for these inspiring
suggestions it's very clear that not
only should we do something but there
are a lot of great things to do um
focusing a little bit more specifically
on one of them one of the ways in which
we can have influence through through
voting through politics I wanted to come
back a little bit to um an issue that
that you Joo brought up there
traditionally foreign policy has stopped
at Water's Edge and more recently
there's been this sort of unfortunate
politization a little
bit maybe Republican versus Democrat of
an issue which
ought to have nothing to do with whether
you whether you're fiscally conservative
or not whether you're whether you're
left or whether you're right and and
even right now I think it's important to
remember that it still is not a left
right issue and if you look more a
little bit more nuanced and closely at
it you have people for also like on the
libertarian side or anything but
Democrat you have people like ran Paul
Ron Paul Etc who very much wanted want
to spend less money on on nuclear
weapons so the the question I would like
to throw out to all of you is there
there is a great opportunity this year
to try to get this more discussed in in
upcoming presidential debates Etc I'd
love to hear if anyone has any thoughts
for what we can do and now I actually
don't mean we as in the people of the us
we in this room to try to inject this as
one of the legitimate um debate topics
in the
debates and and try to get get
candidates even in the primaries to
actually commit the things anyone want
to bite this um bullet yeah
marry um so I know something that Global
zero the American friend service
Committee in Mass peace action has
worked really hard on New Hampshire and
Iowa um was bird dogging and it's really
really fun um essentially if you haven't
heard of bird dogging you basically
follow candidates around the campaign
Trail and ask them questions about the
issue you care about in our case nuclear
weapons and our three um groups have
been successful at getting candidates on
record saying that they would
support support some of the things that
we support um so that's I think one
really fun and also very great
idea so we can do this at multiple
levels uh I was honored to be asked by
Senator Sanders to be an adviser to his
campaign so I'll see what I can do on
that
[Music]
end I hate to sound so pessimistic but I
I think this primary season these
debates have been so dysfunctional and
so ludicrous that I would just assume
the subject did not come up between the
[Laughter]
debates yeah I don't live in this
country so when I watch and see how
things are talked about um in media
outside of here it's uh it's really
interesting one of the things that I've
seen come up a lot is that some of the
bold bold statements that really expose
the illegitimacy of nuclear weapons um
that gets transmitted in my media at
home so when when you do see something
and a lot of things that have come out
from Trump that just make it sound so
insane it actually really helps our
national discussions about the
legitimacy of nuclear weapons because it
looks like this is a dumb weapon uhoh we
better figure out how to not be involved
with it
um yeah good right right on right yeah
well I'd have to agree with Dr Perry but
since I have the microphone I'll briefly
say
I Want To Praise uh uh you know
Professor Ernie Mon and the work he's
done working in the Obama Administration
of Secretary of Energy especially on the
Iran nuclear deal I mean just the
connections he had through this great
school and uh you know he deserves you
know a medals for the work not just he
has done but others that support him
especially a lot of technical people
scienti and Engineers to help this
nuclear deal uh take place you know
still a lot lot to be done with the deal
but I think uh Ernie mon deserves a lot
of credit just uh just to insert a
little bit of of MIT color here it was
some of you may not know that the lead
technical negotiator on the Iranian side
also went to MIT and studied nuclear
engineering so he so so that they had
this strange bonding over their over
there the whole MIT connection and they
they had a lot of things in common which
sort of transcended the national
differences there I think and the baby
clothes too I think the Iranian uh had
this his daughter had a child and then
Ernie came back here went to the MIT pop
and and bought some baby gear baby
clothes put
some right well I think there are two
different levels uh one is the actual
debates which I think are very
significant events that uh command the
national audience and and get a lot of
attention
and I think it would be an excellent
project for the future of Life Institute
to sculpt a particular question that we
could get behind and sub and publicize
to journalists so that one of the people
on the
debate committee would actually pose
this question and if we can get the
right question posed I think it could be
very significant uh so this is this is
just to follow up on that this is a
little bit like in The Hitchhikers guy
the Galaxy well you have the answer what
is the question so what is the question
that that you would recommend on the
panel that should be asked if there's
one that could be somehow inserted into
the
debate well I think somehow would have
to be artfully crafted but somehow the I
the to get the idea
that the direction of nuclear motion
should be towards
reduction if we can make that an issue
that's CL clarified and maybe
distinguished the candidates I think
that would be a very important thing
because I think the general public is
very much or could easily become very
much uh of the opinion that reduction is
the right way to go on the other hand
the donor class the Republican party as
it exists not so much so that could be
an important
distinction uh in the longer run I know
the American physical Society has sub Ed
uh detailed class uh questions series of
questions to candidates who have
responded uh in that case uh the
audience is is different it's not uh and
I think also the people answering the
questions are different it's not not the
candidates themselves but their staffs
and they're carefully thought out uh and
those I think could be important in the
longer term for getting on the record
commitments to
specific meaningful issues so I think
that two-tiered approach one crisp
dramatic question for the debates
themselves and then a series of
questions well thought out that would
get long-term commitments from the
candidates uh well I I think to some
extent the Republican candidates and
what they have said directly or
indirectly about nuclear weapons is
forcing the Democrats to say something
about reducing the dangers of nuclear
war uh both Trump and Crews uh have
attitudes about nuclear weapons that are
so frightening even Obama had something
to say about it yesterday uh and and so
I think
what will happen is that when the
debates occur between the Republican and
the Democrat
whichever it is uh the Democrat is going
to have to use that issue as an
important one and to the extent that we
can feed the questions or the answers to
the Democratic candidate uh we will be
okay but I don't know how to do that
really lots of great ideas there another
recurrent theme I've heard throughout
the day here that it seems everybody
agrees on is that we want to
stigmatize n nuclear weapons production
we want people to understand that it's a
bad thing not a good thing and it's very
it's empowering to think about how
things can gradually become stigmatized
even when they were once considered very
cool
like raise your hand if you're over 60
for example do you remember how cool
smoking used to be when you were kids
when the news anchors used to smoke and
all the hottest actors and actresses
would smoke on television and so on you
know but right
now it's we haven't outlawed
smoking but it isn't considered cool
anymore if I see someone smoking here on
campus they pretty much take for granted
that they're not a student and uh it's
and and then I also assume that they're
probably trying to quit actually because
and smoking as result is very is way way
down so I would love to hear go around
one here and see if you want would put
out one
idea for for your favorite idea for
stigmatizing nuclear weapons making them
rather than having people think of them
as this cool thing that we absolutely
have to have to blow up asteroids or or
feel safe or or you name it as something
which is
really has a yuck factor something which
is really just a problem we want to try
to get rid of gradually so uh do you
want to start over on your end again
Mary
okay okay um so I think this is
something that Global zero does really
well um like the cool Factor right um so
Global zero I think first of all social
media is a really awesome tool for doing
this um and I know that Global zero has
like bumper stickers like there's one
that says just don't do it with the Nike
sign or is like there's a card Against
Humanity card that says like nukes
Against Humanity or I don't know just um
pop culture and social media I think are
huge tools to disseminate this message
um and I also think at least from a the
perspective of of a 20-some if I see a
bunch of my friends out at a rally
against nuclear weapons I'm going to
think it's probably something cool that
I should do um or at least want to know
more about so I think just just um if if
a lot of people are are doing it I think
there's power in numbers
at uh We've looked at this at plowshares
Fund in fact for those interested if you
Google plowshares cultural strategy you
come up with this wonderful report that
we had done just about two years ago now
that looked at how these social
Transformations happen how how did the
American public change their views so
dramatically on on things like gay
marriage or the Vietnam War or civil
rights or smoking what happens there and
there's a big big role for popular
culture in this I mean things like Will
and Grace had a huge role in changing
how the American public looked at gay
people because of the way will was was
portrayed in that show and other shows
so we've been looking at this and trying
to see if we could change the way
nuclear weapons are portrayed in culture
change them from part of the solution to
part of the problem so for examp example
you know nuclear weapons are often seen
as our Ultimate Security our ultimate
Pro protector it's the thing that saves
the Earth Will Smith flies a nuclear
bomb up into the belly of the alien
Mothership in Independence Day you know
Iron Man flies a nuclear weapon into the
transdimensional port hole and kills the
Alien Invasion there Pacific Rim etc etc
as compared to the Dark Knight Rises
where Batman risks his life to fly a
nuclear weapon away from Gotham before
it can destroy it in most of them
they're the hero they're the solution
but in some of them they're the problem
so we want to see if we can't work with
directors not to make a movie about
nuclear weapons but just as they use
this as a plot element how do they show
it how do they portray it and not just
in movies but in in in games Fallout
4 I I would say most of you don't know
what Fallout 4 is but a whole bunch of
you do and have wasted huge Mo moments
of your life playing fall fall out for
depicts nuclear weapons in a very I
would say realistic way these are the
things that end life on this planet and
that's we want more of
that in my book I say and that nuclear
weapons we believed for decades during
the Cold War that nuclear weapons were
vital to preserve our
security uh the message today I believe
is that n nuclear weapons are a danger
to our
security thank you um I agree I think a
lot of it is also looking at the impact
um you use nuclear weapon no matter
where it gets used it's going to have a
negative and a catastrophic impact um
because of that catastrophic impact um
over about about 2third of un almost
two-thirds of the UN member states are
looking at ways to make them illegal and
to negotiate a new legal instrument to
prohibit nuclear weapons is this
something the United States is going to
sign on to probably
not but that external pressure
um from this kind of this nuclear
weapons ban and a Prohibition illegal
prohibiting nuclear weapons is going to
help to stigmatize nuclear weapons
within the United States and it's going
to help all of our activities and that's
because of the impact um of that these
weapons can have so keep your eyes open
on the International Space as well
because I'll tell you a ban is
coming all
right so uh people talking to people and
there's no such thing as a en public we
have to segment messages and go to the
places that Mary and Joe in particular
were talking about in popular culture
especially two things I'll I'll mention
Madame
secretary last Sunday uh you know Sister
organization Bolton Atomic scientist
they got mention of the Doomsday Clock
on Madam Secretary I think it's a well-
watched TV show the TV show I would like
to get our message from the scientists
and Engineers of the world is Big Bang
Theory I love the Big Bang Theory and as
Max said I'm a I'm a geeky guy and and
my wife loves it too and she was an
English major she's an English teacher
she's been saying for years got to get
that Big Bang Theory and they've
mentioned Oppenheimer and fan on Big
Bang Theory but nothing as far as I
recall about nuclear weapons and
stigmatizing
it okay
well I don't I don't think there's a
large constituency that thinks nulear
weapons are
cool I don't think that's the problem I
think the problem let me just clarify I
think there's a large constituency
though who think that they make us safe
they make us safe yes or that they uh
protect it dep and Al it also depends on
who us is or that we have grievances
that can only be worked out or we can
only protect ourselves through nuclear
weapons and I think you know it's it's
it Big Bang Theory won't help uh with uh
with Vladimir Putin or the Russian it
won't help defuse uh terrorist use of
nuclear weapons it won't help defuse the
Russians possibly feeling threatened and
wanting to have nuclear security or the
Iranians so I think we have to uh
address Grievances and manage grievances
as well as not as popular culture
popular culture is is wonderful for the
United States and I think is important
but I don't think it Sol the problem
here do it's a obviously a good strategy
to try all the good ideas people have
and see what pans out so on the on the
particular issue of of uh addressing
grievances do you want to give a little
more of an explicit example of what what
you have in mind well I think managing
grievances well you know I'm a physicist
not
a an expert on international relations
but certainly uh in recent times the uh
successful negotiations negotiations
with Iran I think were tremendously
important and a great
achievement and that was an example I
mean it's very it's uh it's different
cases different people have different
kinds of
grievances uh I also think oh one I I
wanted to had another remark here which
is uh not only there's there are two
there are two approaches to this kind of
negative and positive the the neg the
negative approach is making the nuclear
weapons seem less cool and that's good
but there's another important aspect
which is to uh
reward
uh positive efforts and uh for instance
I think that uh stanislav Petro who was
mentioned here uh he should get a Nobel
Prize I me he he was an example of an
individual who made a decision that was
very important could be as a model for
other people you know people who decide
no I'm not going to do that make a big
difference since you H since you happen
to have one of these little shiny things
do they ask you the noble committee only
to nominate physics prizes or can you
nominate peace prizes too well you
wouldn't be allowed to tell us of course
but well I don't know if it's I don't
think it's a secret no I'm I I get to
nominate in physics and chemistry but of
course I can without being solicited
just add my two
cents any any profession
depends
on hist good idea Gary yeah I'd like to
go back to uh the question how do you
make it cool for young people to oppose
nuclear weapons and nuclear war uh and
again the first step is to educate them
about the effects of nuclear weapons in
nuclear war if we could get all the
young people to attend these meetings we
we'd be in great shape but of course we
don't uh but those of us who teach uh
have opportunities to tell our students
about uh the effects of nuclear weapons
and nuclear war and we can promote
groups that are cropping up around the
country like Global zero and uh chapters
of Peace
action to uh form sponsor them help them
figure out programs that will spread the
word and I think for some reason that I
don't understand I think we're at a good
point right now for generating that kind
of interest and enthusiasm for
change good I think let just say go
ahead I want to say that I want to
congratulate you personally on the
future of Life Institute and what's it's
doing and I think you know trying many
different things that you're doing with
uh the internet with meetings like this
uh is a wonderful thing to do and we'll
see what works try them
all thank you for your kind words thank
you for your support and being part of
the of fli of course as well very very
very grateful for your help Frank so on
on this uh Update note that you made
there Gary I think this is the perfect
um way to segue into um opening up the
questions for all of you I'm sure there
are many so you can race here but don't
fall take it easy to the microphone phon
and remember remember remember questions
not speeches or or very long statements
keep briefer you keep them the more fun
questions we will get through and we'll
probably we'll try to do it also so that
rather than every person on the panel
answering everything will try to have
most one or two feel them so uh you ran
very quickly the mic you get asked first
yeah so I actually have a question for
the physics professors in the audience
um would you I mean for example there's
a lot of physics phds who go on to work
at nuclear weapons Labs or defense
contractors so you as Educators have you
thought about stigmatizing these
employers or have you ever discouraged
your grad students or grad students in
your department to not work at these
institutions or for these
companies you want to comment on
that uh well I've wanted to bring up uh
a point that that's related to this and
to what I've been saying all along that
physicists in their training tend not to
learn much about nuclear weapons and
physicists in their training are
freshmen juniors seniors graduate
students
and in order to address what is a big
lack in education that I personally
myself had I've related this in the
workshop I was a graduate student at the
University of Chicago and many of my
teachers worked on the Manhattan Project
they never talked about it we never
discussed nuclear fishing and it years
later I wondered what was going on that
prevented this from being talked about
Herbert Anderson uh Sam Allison these
were people intimately in involved in
the Manhattan Project well that has to
change and many of us in the physics
Community think that this should change
and so we're presenting a letter to the
American physical Society asking to
recommend that all members of the
society that teach physics to
undergraduates and graduates will
incorporate issues of nuclear weapons
and the nuclear arms race uh in their
coursework it's very easy to go from
introducing the notion of energy to
nuclear energy to nuclear fishion and so
we're going to be circulating these
these letters to our colleagues in the
physics community and asking to bring
the recommendation to all the members of
the society which is a fairly large
group great Frank do you want to chime
in here also since uh you were called
out as a physicist anybody here who's a
member of the aps or a student member of
the aps find Gary afterwards and sign
up yes I think uh deeper involvement
with education is very appropriate and
important
uh in my personal experience this issue
has never really come up I've had former
students go into Finance
I'm not sure if that's better or worse
than uh but and in anyway I have mixed I
would have mixed feelings about it
because the work is going to get done
and it's a question of whether it's
going to be done well or badly uh I
think the real the the level at which
these issues have to be addressed is not
so much the technical is level uh but
the political level making choices of
what we want to do yeah you Charles
you're also part of the physics Mafia
what do you think lot of questioners but
I think this is a very important
question and I'll try to be very brief
um the thing is we're going to need
talented engineers and scientists still
working in the weapons Labs part of the
reason is what Dr Perry's answer to my
question because you know the reverse
the Manhattan Project to
dismantle the weapons and to safeguard
the nuclear materials for decades to
come will need talented technically
trained people to do that and uh you
know by a time I can tell you my
personal history of going to Los Alamos
spending two summers there and then
finally making a decision to leave the
the Nuclear Navy um you know save that
for some other time but I've lived
through that I I was at the end of the
Cold War I'm old enough to experience
that so but we still need these people
going into that field yeah just as a
physicist not not as the chair of the
panel I just want to add to that that um
I agree that we don't would be a mistake
of course for all
idealistic people with technical skills
to stay away from from where these
decisions are made on the other hand I
think it's at the same time very
important that we Define the goal of
physics and more broadly of science not
as just B building cool whizbang things
just for the heck of it because we can
or because someone pays us for it but
build it because we want to make the
world a better place and ask why and
this is something which I I think we all
feel very com comfortable teaching in
class and telling our students about and
it's also something very deeply rooted
here going all the way up to Maria Zuber
and to our president Rafael R who like
to say in in commencement speeches that
look we are about not doing techn the
goal here is not to develop technology
period the goal here is to develop
technology to create a better
future add one more thing that I think
it's important for scientists to go into
uh this kind of Applied work to maintain
scientific standards this came up very
much in uh in the Strategic Defense
Initiative for instance where there was
a level of dishonesty and you know
taking the money and running that I
think uh real scientists should not have
participated in and should not
participate in and if and there's
another good example it's good if you
have a scientist there is good and
idealistic and and instead of just
taking the money and shutting up they
blow the whistle and say look this This
is BS you know then they it was good
that they went into so we have U that
was a question that was that spurred a
lot of response at your turn one of the
Hope in terms of nuclear has been the
growth of the nuclear weapon free zone
all over the world and uh um at the UN
they've been asking more Nations have
been asking more and more for a Middle
East nuclear free zone so with Obama
working on the iron deal that could
bring us closer to a Middle East weapon
of mass destruction free zone um we
could see eventually the US has a weapon
of mass destruction free zone that's
very idealistic but it would be nice to
see all right the I don't think that I
think that was more of a of a a vision
and hope than than a question so let's
go on to
you my question or my question is a
slightly different level I'm with the
American friend service committee and
with its tradition of quiet diplomacy we
have a program based in China that does
work in North Korea and and my my
question is either to Mr cicerone or to
secretary Perry I received a email last
night from our staff in China uh asking
uh what what was the meaning or what
came out of Obama's meeting with prime
minister ab and uh president Park maybe
with Z as well XA ping in relationship
to North Korea's uh uh nuclear weapons
program do you do you have any
information in terms of what came out of
those discussions
[Music]
no but do you want one of us has
actually negotiated with the North
Koreans do you want to say anything
about North Korean what you
might uh well I'll just give you one an
anecdote from my meeting in pongyang
about a decade and a half ago as I
arrived there representing President
Clinton I was out of office by now I was
back at Stanford but he asked me to be
his
Envoy to to deal with the North Koreans
and I went over
and first night I got there I met with
the president of North Korea who's kind
of a functional person no serious but he
had my agenda and I looked at it and I
said there's no military man on this
agenda I want to meet with one of your
senior military people I was the
Secretary of Defense I want to talk with
your military people
so the next morning sure enough I walked
into the meeting and there was this
North Korean General standing there and
he came over to me and said I'm General
such and such he said this meeting was
not my idea I was told to meet with
you he said I don't think we should be
even
discussing giving up nuclear
weapons and well i' like somebody puts
it on the line like that and so I said
why do you think you need nuclear
weapons and he said to protect protect
ourselves I said from whom he said from
you now this was a good many years ago
it was during the time when the uh
United States and NATO were
bombing uh
Serbia and he said if you send bombs on
the pongyang we will retaliate with
nuclear weapons on your cities pause not
excluding
paloalto right
Hometown the meeting actually went on to
a very good discussion after that but
that that got it off to a pretty good
start I
thought wonderful so let's see which
side are we on now you oh so first of
all I believe the uh woman who just
spoke did have a question correct me if
I'm wrong I think it was about was there
hope for a nuclear free zone in the
Middle East was that your question ma'
yes oh I I apologize for
misunderstanding this so does someone
want to chime in on that dim dim uh it's
it comes up all the time we've
been we've never been
close the I think you're right the the
stopping the Iranian nuclear program
stopping another war in the Middle East
was a mage you had to do that in order
to have any hope of getting to a Middle
East free of nuclear weapons but there's
still such antagonism such chaos in the
region Egypt who's been the major
sponsor of this
is is is is in a very weak position at
this point it's not at the top of their
agenda so no I wouldn't anticipate any
progress on that front at all for the
foreseeable future anybody disagree with
that
that Miller has made this beautiful
Globe here which actually shows all the
nuclear free zone sadly they look a
little bit deflated at the moment
hopefully we can is a nuclear free zone
yeah go ahead I think it's very one yeah
one so great question you have to
differentiate between a nuclear weapon
free zone in the Middle East and a
weapons of mass destruction free zone so
you know if you look at is Israeli right
okay yeah so uh why I would say you know
we have some hope with the Iran deal
with nuclear Syria Syria is a big
freaking mess and but with chemical
weapons people criticize President Obama
for The Stance he took but I think it
was the right move and we got the
Russians to actually cooperate and work
with us and we think we've probably
dismantled and destroyed most of those
chemical weapons that Assad and Syria
had and so that's progress and I think
that could address part of Israel's
concern as well you know the big secret
in the room I once gave a talk in a a
weapons laboratory I won't say which one
you can pick which one of the three and
I was told and I was talking about work
I done with with secretary Perry and
general scor Croft and they said Charles
what one request do not mention that
Israel has nuclear weapons we're not
allowed to say that here at this this
this National Laboratory or any of the
Laboratories I won't say which
laboratory but it was
yeah so I had a question too I was just
clarifying that um woman spoke before me
had a question so also Doctor Who has
had a history of making very subtle
anti- bomb thing so just uh endorsement
there also they've been putting
political agendas into children's Minds
since 196 3 just saying anyway um the
question I had so obviously I'm a young
person but I'm also a Creator I'm a
writer I'm a musician how does that play
in I know that's kind of a strange
question but to those of you who aren't
named Mary because I talk to you all the
time um uh how do I as a young Creator
fit into the
story
um Frank I think was a NC ahead and then
and then
Susie
well there are some marvelous examples
of uh Creations artistic Creations based
that are uh uh I think important in in n
in uh in the nuclear
weapons uh culture thinking about it uh
of course uh Doctor Strange
Love
yeah oh well that that's the first step
you should
take so if could do a sequel to Doctor
Strange Love or something that could be
shown in association with it that's a
great platform uh there are these there
were two television series that I don't
remember the name of but the day after I
think the day after was one that had
that was discussed earlier had Direct
influence on Ronald Reagan so uh and
then developed some apps develop some
games there are many many possibilities
for well you have to work with the team
but yeah there are many possibilities I
think for uh dramatizing these issues
they are tremendously important human
issues uh secretary Perry showed us a
tremendous tremendously affecting video
uh Max Max had also a an effective video
so so there there are lots of
opportunities I think thank you yeah I
just want to say something um earlier
today you told us in a in the workshop
about a small video that you had made
then you shared that on Twitter with the
MIT nukes hashtag um and then I saw that
getting retweeted and retweeted and
retweeted keep making stuff okay so
you're making stuff keep doing it you're
doing it really yeah no seriously keep
doing it because if as you do it the
more you do it you're going to get
better at it people are going to see it
more people are going to be inspired to
do it you are an educator now thank
you
so so you can do stuff like this you can
just throw it out there but you know it
really helps if you have a hook if you
hook it to something that's already
going on so for example uh Dr Perry did
a tremendous oped uh about a month ago
now calling on President Obama to kill
just one weapon system kill the new
cruise missile it is perhaps the most
destabilizing dangerous weapon in this
banquet of nuclear weapons we have
coming this particular one is
susceptible one
to tremendous
destabilizing uh effects if it's
actually deployed two if we don't build
this perhaps the United States could
take the lead in banning all nuclear Cru
cruise missiles as Dr Perry points out
and and three we might actually be able
to knock this sucker off we might
actually be able to do it so hook your
creativity to this because when you do
something like that for as an example
when you do something like that then he
sees it his Institute picks it up the
Perry project picks it up Global zero
pick it up I pick it up and then boom
you know you're you're going into
something that's already already
happening already moving uh I have
one it
is yes uh
one uh remembrance what one of the
people who inspired me to be involved in
anti-nuclear work was lonus Pauling and
lonus Pauling and his collaborators
managed to get the uh atmospheric test
band treaty passed and the way one of
the methods they used was to focus on
the radioactive material that was
blanketing the Earth because of these
tests of larger and larger hydrogen
bombs strontium
90 is a radioactive element that's
related to calcium in the periodic table
and it gets into the bones and so
falling and company started a campaign
to have mothers and and dads send their
children's baby teeth to a common place
and the baby teeth were tested for
radioactivity and it was true I mean the
Earth is
still uh blanketed with strontium 90
which has a halflife of some 30 years
from those tests well I'm bringing this
up because there's great Focus now on
the zika virus which is causing birth
defects uh quite dramatic and terrible
well radi radiation causes birth defects
and we know about that from hirosima and
Nagasaki and from the tests that were
done in the Marshall Islands in the
Pacific and it seems to me that if
people become aware of what kind of
birth defects have resulted and can
result from nuclear
weapons uh this is one way to get the
message across thank you so much guys
great so we're we're getting dangerously
close to the witching hour here I think
we're going to go into just a little bit
of overtime since there's there so many
people standing up here but let's think
of this a little bit as speed dating so
very quick questions very quick answers
so we
can get everybody a voice here yes so
PhD in physics MIT uh one of the
questions that go to the coolness Factor
addressing that uh so I've been working
on the divestment campaign in fossil
fuels and I was wondering if you had
been thinking of any real collaborations
with the climate movement because even
in this discussion even our group once
you measure no nuclear weapons you kind
of go into the like no nuclear at all
and you kind of like lose a lot of
people that would support you and so
have you thought of any real
collaborations in terms of like even
public awareness or education and also
just kind of like building allies that
way so you could spread the message
faster as chair of the organizing
committee that was a
central as the chair of the program
committee that was a central theme right
from the beginning how could we get some
of the students who and faculty who are
mobilized around divesting from fossil
fuels how could we get them to work
together and finally decided Well maybe
if we had a conference a few would come
CU I was yeah that's why I was on the
panel but I was kind of wondering for
you at your level have you been thinking
about this we absolutely have and please
email me we want to talk to you because
if anybody who cares about plus 2° C
should also care about minus 20°
C do you want to make a quick comment
Charles yeah I think that the natural
technical energy source is nuclear
energy I know it's cont verial and some
people environmental movement but there
are noted climate scientists like Jim
Hansen who's very pro-nuclear energy
nuclear energy you know can't solve this
problem we need you know a lot of silver
bullets so to speak but I think that
could be a bridging uh issue to for
those two communities and Alan robok
himself is a bridging bridge between the
two communities nuclear winter was
brought to our attention by climate
scientists question just kindest
respects to all the panelists thank you
and thank you uh Dr teg Mark for uh uh
hosting this discussion and and yeah
just thank you for hosting this
discussion which is not um which is
conducive even to a passionate
disagreement if you try to go to a trump
rally and do that you'll just get kicked
out so thank you um just wanted to
mention that uh I I just think that uh
Martin Luther King and Douglas MacArthur
really had it right when they said that
unless we build a world completely
without war and based on Peaceful
collaboration amongst Nations we will
simply go extinct and I would just say
that I think secretary John kery the
other day in his comments on his
discussion with the American and Russian
astronauts and uh highlights that kind
of collaboration which we need to strive
for and I would mention one more thing
is that China has offered to collaborate
with us on uh the new Silk Road economic
development project to end poverty and I
think that uh we should take that up and
if anybody on the panel has a a comment
on how we might be able to achieve that
kind of collaboration
on the US end uh that would be much
appreciated thank you thank
you okay um question um I think it was
about 15 years ago Jonathan Sher wrote a
very to me very interesting essay called
The Gift of time that some of us may
remember and one piece came up there
which I found conceptually helpful I'm
not a scientist or engineer he made a
distinction between what he called
vertical and horizontal nuclear
disarmament as I understand it vertical
is simply getting rid of the warheads
and The Delivery Systems horizontal is
looking at the production process maybe
even the educational process the sort of
pieces that fit together which
ultimately produce the actual weapons
themselves and my sense is that the Iran
agreement actually tried to do this kind
of horizontal dis disarmament I'm not
sure if that's correct but it also
strikes me and I may well be wrong here
it's strikes me that perhaps if you work
at the horizontal level then you run
into less major political obstacles it's
perhaps somewhat more kind of
technocratic if you will anyway I don't
know if this is fruitful and if anybody
wants to comment on that as a possible
approach just real quick while you're
thinking of your answer you know I think
one of the reasons we all so many of us
liked the Prague speech and the
president's um uh policy was he got it
right it was it was an
integrated um approach you had to do
three things you have to stop terrorists
from getting their weapon from getting
their hands on the material stop nuclear
terrorism you had to stop new countries
from getting these weapons and you had
to reduce the existing arsenals and you
have to do all of these things and you
have to do them all at once because
progress on one feeds progress on the
other and setbacks on one set you back
on the other the the vision was
absolutely correct the analysis was
correct he made
advances on two of them
particularly with the Iran deal and he
just couldn't quite get the third and
the the thing is faltered it's so it's
it's incomplete but the but the the the
project is still there waiting to be
renewed I associate myself with what
Joey just
[Laughter]
said I Associated myself for these all
right hi um I'm a concern international
relations student at TS um my question
is about uh deterrence and like
strategic deterrence so maybe more
towards Dr Percy um I'm we're taught
that an important element of deterrence
is The credibility of the threat so um
persuading the actor maybe Russia that
um we are actually willing to to excert
the the threat and and to keep keep
Russia or whatever actor persuaded that
um there's that the willingness to use
this threat is real and so I was kind of
wondering like what like um what what's
the effect of this kind of limitation on
on what we can do if if if if it's if
it's important or if it's taught that
it's important that we keep the
perception of this threat real um and
maybe how we can get around this
limitation I don't
know anyone want to feel
that this relates to a question about
Russia which has come back many many
times and let me just let me just TW
twist the question a little bit and see
if someone wants to chime in We were
originally told that we needed all these
nuclear weapons to prevent the global
spread of
Communism now we're told that we still
need them and and
somehow the current arms race
feels much less like this ideological
battle communism or or capitalism and it
feels much more somehow like they run up
to World War I where nobody could really
expl point to exactly what it was that
was the ideological difference this but
nonetheless they hated each other's guts
and and and then everybody thought the
war wouldn't really break out and a
bunch of weird coincidences took place
gabu decided to assassinate Arch Duke
fer in Belgrade and then poof five years
later everybody was like hm what were we
thinking um so could if someone wanted
to just talk a little bit more about the
whole Russia situation what you see if
you feel that there is something really
fundamental driving it like there was in
the in the communism days or or if not
what is it that's that's so driving this
that's so un supposed to be so
unsolvable yeah I think Max you are
clarifying it and it's it's a good
question and I would say two things one
is that I think Dr Perry's absolutely
right that sole purpose of nuclear
weapons going you know hopefully near
very near term is that just to deter use
of other nuclear weapons period and
that's challenging enough to get that
policy forward and and you know I think
Joe renion gave an excellent speech
about all the challenges we had in OB
bom Administration the resistance
internl Administration but and maybe
she's getting at Ukraine you know should
the United States and NATO said look you
know don't don't you know encroach on
Ukraine Vladimir Putin and Russia
because but get a Core strategic
National interest you're getting that
slipper slope and and uh you know those
are core russian interests as well and
so you know I don't think we should be
making nuclear threats idy and I think
this gets back to sole purpose
underscore should just be deterring
other nuclear weapons just
to provoke you a little bit more I mean
if clearly if if you the sole goal of
having nuclear weapons is deterrence
then one could adopt the strategy like
what China has now uncertain retaliation
thing they have about 200 nukes but they
are really big the fandong and uh
they're not on ha trigger alert but
they're moving around you know we figure
if we do a first strike we're probably
going to lose at least 50 of our biggest
cities we don't want to do that and it's
enough um so neither the neither the
Russian nor the
American nuclear Arsenal looks anything
like the Chinese so you can't really
explain it as being only about the
turns about 100 or
fewer so what is it about maybe this is
a very good candidate for our question
whether the candidates would be willing
to commit to no first use of nuclear
weapons or to a long-term strategy where
would be yeah yeah it would be clear
that the uh bright red line which has
really been the Saving Grace of the
whole nuclear situation that they don't
get used period uh that that that that
be
maintained that our policy be based on
that percep
Jo this real quick and I won't elaborate
but it's different now than it was 30
years ago or even even 10 years ago I
don't believe ideology plays the
dominant driver here I don't believe the
differences over the nature of
deterrence play the dominant driver
although they're they're present I
believe politics are a big part of this
I I'm if we had had a Republican
president who had been proposing the
things that Obama proposed they would
have already named an airport after him
we we we would it would have been the
start would have been done deal with
Iran would have been done you know
wouldn't have been this big fight the
politicalization but the main driver is
right now I believe that the nuclear
industrial complex not the military
industrial complex there's lots of
people doing military I just mean those
people with a vested interest in the
contracts and positions and billets that
come from this complex so one of the
obstacles to the new start treaty wasn't
the negotiations with the Russians it
was the negotiations with the ICBM
caucus in the white H in the in the
Congress Democrats and Republicans who
went to the president and said you can't
go lower in those negotiations because
you'll be cutting into the icbms you
cannot cut into the icbms why because of
deterrence because of ideology because
of physics no because they got 2,000
jobs in Montana period that's it you
know you know so we got to find ways to
go and attack that to convince the
business and political leaders of these
ICBM states that it's in their vested
interest to cash in this chip of
declining value for something else a new
Mission a new Revenue stream and if we
can do that if you can convince them
that Montana should no longer be welcome
to Montana America's nuclear
sponge where our mission is to absorb
Warheads if we can convince them of that
we can break the back of this
thing all right
um a lot of very creative ideas here we
do uh want to honor our promise to let
you out here this is not some sort of
MIT detention where we have to stay
after hours so uh what we're going to do
is I think we're going to take who who's
next to the two of you we'll give one
question one more question to each side
and then the panelist May if you smile
at them nicely choose to sit here and
answer if more questions afterwards
informally okay book that's in the
meantime there will be book signings we
can do parallel processing this is MIT
so so um you you were first right you
were first hi uh I'm a confused graduate
student and then we're in physics and uh
I was wondering about so in the public
discourse uh having nuclear weapons is a
deterrent um however I saw when Ma
showed the the map of all the US targets
uh from like 50 years ago
all of Russia Eastern Europe had a DOT
and if you look at the map that the
Russia probably has then we all are
covered in dots whereas interestingly
enough none of the nuclear free zones
none of the white regions behind you had
any dots on them so my my question to to
you guys is is it is it a better
deterrent to have nuclear weapons or to
not have nuclear
[Applause]
weapons so you're you're saying um
I that is the conclusion that that most
of the states who have signed the
nonproliferation treaty have come to
that they're better off if they don't
have nuclear weapons and all their
neighbors have nuclear weapons I thought
this point you you you made Eileen that
the entire southern hemisphere is
nuclear free is is is remarkable and you
know the people nobody made Africa have
a nuclear free zone nobody made South
America have a nuclear free zone They
decided this is where their security lay
and and and I I think that's the right
calculation great and last but not least
um my name is Justina I'm a freshman
here at MIT and I would like to thank
all the panelists for being here
today um my question is about education
so um as I see it education in about
nuclear weapons is twofold uh one would
like to educate both everyone about the
dangers of nuclear weapons as well as to
educate all the people who would like to
learn how they actually work and so so
potentially they can go to stem fields
and so on and so forth but how does one
accomplish this does one have to look at
this and say it's a twofold mission or
can one do both at the same time and
then what's the time frame for doing
this
education who wants to feel
[Music]
this okay
uh uh yes I think as I've said the
education about nuclear weapons can
begin with freshman physics and and
first year engineering courses uh
because it it's a natural subject to
address at that point uh the question I
think you're asking is how much do you
want to learn about it and and what do
you want to do with that knowledge uh
you can learn more and more about
nuclear weapons once you get the basics
uh I don't know if there are
courses that particularly address that
but certainly in our modern physics
courses and advanced Nuclear Physics
courses you can learn about fishion and
fusion uh and you can learn enough I
think by reading some good textbooks on
the subject to uh understand why the
Iranian deal
went the way it did and what it has to
do with centrifuges and and why certain
kinds of reactors produce more uh
plutonium than others and so on those
are things that your nuclear engineering
classes here can teach you and do I
think right and we shouldn't limit
ourselves to universities my my
16-year-old son Philip who has patiently
been waiting for his daddy here say why
aren't you coming you know I he I asked
him the other day how how much he's
learned about nuclear weapons in his in
his entire trajectory through the US
school system nothing so far and and I
think we're going to give the very very
last word
to
you well in answer that last
question my course at Stanford devotes
three very intense hours to nuclear
weapons what they are how they're used
what the consequences are um that's
about a few hundred Stanford students a
year get that information I as I told
you I'm converting that into a moo and
so that course will be available on the
internet I hope by the end of the year
so if you want in three if you're
willing to devote three hours to learn
about nuclear weapons get on my moo all
right I want to end uh the the day here
by uh first of
all giving you round of thanks thank you
so much to the wonderful panelists here
let's give it up for them
a big round of thanks also to all of the
speakers we've heard throughout the day
here I've never felt as optimistic
actually about this situation because
there have been so many cool ideas thank
you
everybody